calmez vous disais quelque chose oui moi
ce que je voulais dire c'est que
effectivement nous les fonctionnaires
c'est exactement pareil d'ailleurs vent
monsieur macro sea games serrer la main
je vais même pas lu syrie
je vais juste lui dire mais donnez nous
des moyens des moyens humains augmenté
de salerno
je veux dire je vis est bloqué depuis
deux ans en quoi je veux dire qu'est ce
que c'était mieux avant pour savoir
jusqu'à quand est-ce que c'était mieux
avant avoue quoi bon avec les autres
gouvernements parce que c'était mieux
mais bon je suis un type haïti vous
allez voter au pied qu'est-ce qu'il
aimerait devenir vous avez voté pour qui
et moi j'ai voté blanc d'accor d'anf et
j'aimerais bien que les votes soient
considérés comptabilise et alimente à
diviser ça c'est sûr
d'accord bien sûr la survenue des
discussions bien sûr que c'est au menu
de la discussion c'est parce que vous
avez manifesté lundi david guinard
inquiète qu'il est noir à la fin du mois
de mai je vous parle du japon du c'est
gilles verdez alexis qu alexis corbière
privée sic nous mais devenir danger tous
les jours on le sait vraiment c'est vrai
qu'elle nous on a quand même des enfants
qu'ils ne s'installent si le soir ils
vont nous trouver
on a des enfants qui commencent vendredi
avec les insomnies n'obtient pas ce qu
ils savent pas voilà il ya des dommages
collatéraux celle au civic aussi les
maris les femmes qui restent à la maison
je vais parier qu'à me claes êtes mariés
oui oui c'est marie il est fonctionnel
au nom du tout mais il ya des coups
fonctionnaires les enfants ils sont
confiés aux familles pendant que nous on
est sur le terrain quand on est
quelqu'un de si les rennais à 23h30 dans
la boue 17h l'être humain du crotoy
irakiens je dirais alors après corrihons
l'a interpellé trop tôt on interpelle
n'importe qui mais vous avez vu les
images comment voulez vous qu'on sache
qui on un cartel entre les premiers jeux
alors avant d'entendre alexis corbière
quand vous êtes interpellé comme ça ou
nirvah j'oublie qu'est ce que vous avez
à dire à cette jeune fille qu'est qui
est sur le point de craquer qui dit si
je croise emmanuel macron je ne lui
serrerait pas la main vous auriez fait
pareil avec françois hollande ou nicolas
sarkozy aux élections ils nous
promettent mais alors plaint jones et
dès qu'ils arrivent à la place au soleil
est bien d'accord donc vérifier si les
tickets est le cas mais ça fait comme
maintenant que vous ne votez plus pour
les présidentielles agen va t il
appelant toujours blu âge
j'aimerais effectivement à l'époque à
l'époque où sarkozy ségolène royal vous
aviez voté pour qui j'ai voté bien
d'accord françois hollande c'est à dire
pour qui ce fait on sait pas que vous
avez
levac kaboul 1 alors à vous dire qu'il y
avait à répondre à cette jeune femme
de toutes les manières vous attendez pas
vraiment de réponse que je pourrais vous
apporter c'est ce qu'on pensait de lui
par contre tous les fonctionnaires de
police tawakal alors moi à titre
personnel au nom du gouvernement je
parle à tous les français et ça fait
plusieurs semaines que les françaises
sont mobilisés pour parler à tout le
monde pour parler et dire qu'on veut se
faire entendre la semaine dernière quand
je suis venu ici il y avait une chose
qui était très attendu c'est qu'ils
aient enfin une parole du président de
la république
ouais enregistré un ca fêterait sa
fêterait sa 5e balle au fond fait ma
dernière ce n'est pas enregistrée mais
la base est fatigué
[Applaudissements]
si j'avais su si vous avez un problème
sur les personnes mal rasé pour me le
dire tout de suite
et moi je fais toujours en direct merci
terry moi je vous demande pas de l'aimer
mais je demande au moins de m'écouter
c'est eux si vous l'avez vu je vous ai
écoutés vous parlez moi je trouve ça
essentiel d'entendre ce que vivent au
quotidien nos forces d'ordre
elles ont été célébrées dans cette
émission au moins une dizaine de fois
aujourd'hui la firme dernière par le
gouvernement par le président de la
république par le premier ministre avec
des mesures financées avec un vrai
regard sur vos carrières avec un regard
sur votre vie quotidienne et les
discussions elles ont lieu en ce moment
alors je sais que c'est compliqué ces
histoires de temps aujourd'hui vous avez
dit madame nous tant qu'on n'a pas tout
ce qu'on a demandé on retournera à la
rue et si ça va jusqu'à la violence
pourquoi pas la viola il se trouve que
ça provoque et ça fait que vous ça vous
fait avant ça fait effectivement la
violence et on se pose la question de
savoir est ce que ce n'est pas la
violence qui avait alors je suis à quai
jusqu'à questionnons j'accuse sont les
héritiers mounir la question que se
posent les titien mine de rien monsieur
ben oui parce que quand elle dit c'est
vrai que voilà on se l'est posée la
semaine dernière nous aussi alors les
jaunes se dit oui mais je sais que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord et que ça eric
naulleau mais mine de rien laetitia ada
a raison de poser la question mais je
suis là pour te dire d'accord je pense
que les casseurs ont changé la donne